[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
Bienvenue c'est sens public votre
rendez-vous quotidien de débat et de
reportage sur public c'est là vous le
savez la promesse elle est dans le titre
de l'émission de l'illusens à
l'actualité vous proposez des clés de
compréhension des mutations de notre
société et justement notre premier thème
c'est la transition écologique au cœur
de ce plan de décarbonation de la France
présentée hier par Elisabeth borne un
effort collectif un objectif de baisse
50% des émissions de gaz à effet de
serre d'ici 2030 mais pas de piste de
financement pour l'instant faut-il taxer
les plus riches comme le propose
économiste Edouard pizani ferry dans le
rapport commandé par le gouvernement ce
sera l'une des questions de notre débat
dans une minute et puis c'est une
spirale mortifère une succession de
réglement de compte qui en deuil les
quartiers nord de Marseille depuis des
mois
l'objectif est clair réduire de 55% nos
émissions de gaz à effet de serre d'ici
à 2030 pour tenir cet objectif il va
falloir faire en disant ce que l'on a à
peine fait en 30 ans Elisabeth borne a
précisé hier la répartition des efforts
à fournir devant le Conseil national de
la transition écologique la moitié des
baisses de CO2 va reposer sur les
entreprises un quart sur les
collectivités et l'autre car sur les
ménages nous devons encore doubler le
rythme de baisse de nos émissions de gaz
à effet de serre dans chaque secteur ces
6 derniers mois ont permis d'identifier
les différents leviers de baisse des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre
cela nous a permis de définir une
répartition de l'effort secteur par
secteur transport bâtiment agriculture
industrie tous les secteurs sont
concernés mais cela a un coût 34
milliards d'euros d'investissement
public en plus chaque année dans le
rapport qui la remise à l'exécutif
l'économiste Jean Pisani Ferri plaide
pour un impôt exceptionnel et temporaire
sur le patrimoine des plus riches au
sein de l'exécutif ce nouvel impôt fait
débat si vous voulez un moment il faut
bien mesurer que cette transition elle
va pas se financer toute seule est-ce
que l'impôt est une solution non pour
une raison qui est simple c'est que les
10% dont parle Jean pisoniféré mais le
mention d'uniquement comme une option
pas comme une nécessité c'est 10% de
contribuables il paye déjà 75% de
l'impôt chez le revenu pour financer la
transition écologique le locataire de
Bercy propose notamment de supprimer les
niches fiscales sur les énergies
fossiles d'alourdir la taxe sur les
véhicules thermiques et de créer un
nouveau plan d'épargne à venir climat
mais pourrons dans tech ne suffira pas
Bruno Le Maire il doit comprendre que
nous sommes dans un monde où l'effort
sur le climat
est essentiel pour l'avenir voir la
survie nos sociétés il y a une urgence
la perspective d'une hausse de 4 degrés
en France métropolitaine d'ici à la fin
du siècle est une piste de travail
sérieuse ce plan climat est-il à la
hauteur des enjeux de la transformation
environnementale en débat tout de suite
avec Jean-François Husson bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes sénateur LR de la
Meurthe-et-Moselle membre du Conseil
national de la transition écologique et
rapporteur général de la commission des
finances du Sénat Elise nakarato bonsoir
bienvenue à vous aussi vous êtes
responsable climat de l'association
Oxfam France Arnaud gosse bonsoir
bienvenue à vous aussi à vos cas
spécialistes du droit de l'environnement
et professeur associé à l'Université
Paris 1 et j'accueille également Émilie
s'appelle ski de ce côté de la table ce
soir éditorialise pour sens publique on
va faire un premier tour de table tiens
pour avoir votre avis peut-être un peu
général sur ce qui a été annoncé par la
première ministre Jean-François ils sont
je crois que vous parlez d'un catalogue
de bonnes intentions pourquoi vous dites
ça alors je dis parce que il y a comme
une approche qui est un peu différente
aujourd'hui il y a me semble-t-il une
prise en compte de la problématique du
changement climatique ce qui est plutôt
quelque chose de nouveau depuis 6 ans et
l'arrivée d'Emmanuel Macron n'a plutôt
des castings avec des opérations plutôt
de marketing politique plutôt qu'avec
une approche sur la réalité de du sujet
changement climatique mais j'ai coutume
de dire je l'ai dit hier j'ai il y a une
petite difficulté par rapport à ce
catalogue de bonnes intentions c'est que
les choses ne sont pas vraiment rangées
et d'ailleurs qu'est-ce qu'on demande
aujourd'hui par exemple au collectivités
locales sur les territoires on dit mener
des plans climats air énergies
territoriaux je mets toujours au dessus
un sujet la thématique de la santé et
finalement c'est là on vient percuter
avec Anne sujet qui vient en complément
sans forcément s'emboîter donc il va y
avoir beaucoup de travail pour essayer
de mettre ça en perspective le mettre en
perspective et faire en sorte que
l'opinion publique
s'approprie le sujet pour ne pas le
rejeter effectivement notre défi est
celui-ci et je le dis on l'acceptation
elle est très importante et on y
reviendra sonnette d'alarme à l'époque
des gilets jaunes on y reviendra
évidemment Elise nakarato on avait un
peu oublié que dans le titre d'Elizabeth
borne il y a écrit première ministre
chargé de la planification écologique et
énergétique vous dites quoi vous dites
enfin
on dit hier on a eu un amuse-bouche et
on attend le plat de résistance parce
qu'effectivement il y a des annonces il
y avait quand même une dizaine de
ministres présents pour présenter ce
plan donc on se dit à une une intention
mais effectivement derrière on n'a pas
de réalité concrète donc
c'est pas trop tôt ça fait quand même
plusieurs années qu'on attend des
actions concrètes ça fait des dizaines
d'années que les scientifiques tirent la
semaine d'alarme mais on peut pas non
plus dire que rien n'a été fait dans le
premier quinquennat il y a eu la loi
AGEC anti gaspi économie circulaire le
lot qui travaille résilience alors on
peut dire que c'est pas un plan général
en suffisamment ambitieux mais on peut
pas dire on ne peut pas dire que rien
n'a été fait mais le Conseil d'État est
encore 15 jours à rappeler que ce qui a
été fait n'est absolument pas à la
hauteur de ce qui devrait être fait en
fait c'est pas une question de on n'est
pas allé assez vite c'est une question
de trajectoire on n'est pas dans les
bons ce n'est pas une question de degré
c'est pas on a les bonnes mesures mais
pas assez vite ce n'est pas les bonnes
on ne va pas dans dans les bonnes
trajectoires pour mettre la France sur
la trajectoire sur laquelle elle s'est
engagée de
un degré 1 degré et demi 55 % donc ce
que les bornes a dit hier donc ça pour
nous c'est une satisfaction aussi de
l'entendre parce que jusqu'à maintenant
la France n'avait pas pris cet
engagement là Arnaud Cosmo qu'est-ce que
vous en pensez allez j'ai 10 tours de
table sur une vision un peu général de
ce plan c'est une excellente chose que
la première ministre se saisisse du
sujet avec un secrétaire général dédié à
la planification écologique ça permet de
faire en sorte que le sujet soit
transversé à toutes les administrations
alors que jusqu'à une période récente le
ministère écologique n'est pas du tout
du ministère malgré sa taille de plus
importante ce n'est pas lui qui était
prépondérant dans les arbitrages
interministériel ça fait très longtemps
que les associations notamment réclament
à ce qu'il y a un pilotage rappelez-vous
c'était même Nicolas Hulot dans son
pacte écologique en 2006 qui prévoyait
déjà un vice-premistre développement
durable donc c'est bien dans la forme
que les ministres voilà tout ça est très
bien sur les objectifs aussi les
objectifs qui sont souvent réitérés par
la première ministre qui connaît bien le
sujet il a été directrice de cabinet du
ministère de l'écologie du temps de
Ségolène Royal elle a été elle-même
ministre peu de temps mais elle connaît
le sujet donc ça sur la forme tout va
bien les objectifs sont bons je ferai
deux critiques la première c'est qu'elle
parle beaucoup d'énergie de climat et
beaucoup moins de biodiversité comme
s'il y avait deux sujets séparés alors
que pour moi ils sont totalement
conjoints et les scientifiques eux-mêmes
le disent oui mais ça c'est un peu
général c'est à dire oui on parle du
GIEC depuis des années alors qu'il y a
aussi des des rayures scientifiques sur
la biodiversité dont on a tout juste
commencé à parler il y a peut-être il y
a peut-être six mois ou un an quoi ouais
si ça donc ça c'est le premier regret à
chaque fois qu'on a dit sur l'écologie
bien souvent on a un discours sur climat
un discours sur la biodiversité on ne
lit pas les deux et pourtant quand vous
pensez climat comment ne pas penser
aussi aux forêts par exemple qui sont
des plus de carbone etc donc ça c'est
très manquant et puis ce qui manque un
petit peu aussi dans son discours c'est
qu'on a l'impression que elle attend
tout de l'État elle aussi or vous êtes
mieux passé que moi pour savoir que
l'essentiel des mesures vient pour ce
qui est des ce type de l'Union
européenne et pour la mise en oeuvre des
collectivités territoriales et des
entreprises des articulations les
entreprises vont être aussi beaucoup mis
à contribution évidemment beaucoup de ce
que doivent faire son gouvernement et
l’état c'est normal mais peut-être aussi
qui manque ces autres échelons alors
l'objectif affiché effectivement 50
réductions de 50 % des émissions de gaz
à effet de serre d'ici 2030 est-ce que
c'est réaliste deuxième grande question
que je vous pose aux uns aux autres
Jean-François Husson est-ce que là parce
que 2030 c'est demain c'est dans c'est
même pas dans 10 dans un ancêtre
je vais faire une réponse politique de
ce que je crois je crois que ça n'est
pas réaliste de penser pouvoir obtenir
ce résultat en 6 ans et demi
voilà alors on va nous dire oui mais il
faut avoir une ambition l'ambition est
plus forte c'est vrai mais on a parlé
donc réchauffement climatique on n'a pas
les biodiversité je vais rajouter un
élément qui est pas tout à fait anodin
la pollution de l'air j'ai présé une
commission d'enquête qui évaluait en
France à peu près dans la fourchette
haute à 100 milliards 100 milliards
d'euros par an le coût pour la France au
moment au moment où la COP 21 demandait
une mobilisation de 100 milliards de
dollars à l'échelle de la planète chaque
année pour atteindre les objectifs de
lutte contre le chômant climatique donc
tout ça ça fait beaucoup de travail
raison pour laquelle je pense qu'il faut
pas tarder et il faut ordonnancer et il
faut mettre par contre effectivement
toutes les catégories en mouvement moi
je crois effectivement les entreprises
mais je vais vous dire le plus important
c'est le financements et il faut aller
chercher les finances privées alors ça
ça le plus important le jour où les
financiers
vont vraiment comprendre où est
l'intérêt à ce moment là je pense qu'on
va enclencher beaucoup plus rapidement
que dans l'incantation de la puissance
publique qui n'en peut mais pour la
France avec 3000 milliards de dettes ça
a commencé il y a des fonds spécialisés
des fonds impacts des fonds climat mais
bon doucement la démarre doucement ils
sont encore c'est encore très
minoritaire par rapport à la masse de
financement qui existe en France ou sur
la planète sur le rythme je reviens vers
vous Elina karato parce que il y a
urgence où on le dit le constat
scientifique il nous le dit
malheureusement depuis longtemps et on
aurait dû s'y mettre évidemment
sans doute il y a 10 ans ou plus mais il
y a quand même une question sur
l'acceptabilité les les consommateurs
les citoyens qui pour certains demandent
aussi d'appuyer sur le frein donc c'est
c'est un peu compliqué de gérer ces deux
injonctions la contradictoire la
question c'est est-ce que c'est réaliste
de continuer à ne rien faire c'est de
dire à se laisser se développer des
canicules des feux de forêt on voit nos
services publics qui sont dans une
catastrophe ext des inondations en ce
moment même en Italie qui sont dus
directement au réchauffement climatique
10 millions de maisons en France qui
sont fissurées à cause des sécheresses
donc est-ce que ça c'est réaliste
comment est-ce qu'on fait pour rendre
nos pas réaliste mais réalisable cette
baisse des émissions de gaz à effet de
serre et vous l'avez dit la réponse pour
ça c'est de d'organiser une transition
juste une transaction qui demande à
chacun chacune aux entreprises à l'État
aux individus de faire en fonction de ce
qu'ils peuvent et notamment en fonction
de leur capacité y compris financières
moi il me semble qu'il y a un aspect qui
a pas été du tout exploré dans cette
présentation c'est le côté challenge en
fait on voit par exemple des pays comme
la Suède qui se sont donnés ce challenge
d'avancer leur transition écologique et
énergétique notamment vraiment d'aller
beaucoup plus vite que ce qu'ils avaient
prévu de pousser les entreprises à
innover et je pense que c'est aussi
comme ça qu'on peut vendre en gros le
plan et pas que contrainte parce que la
contrainte on la connaît et c'est vrai
qu'on arrive tardivement mais si on
était dans quelque chose de plus
collectif comme elle a essayé de de le
dire Elisabeth borne mais aussi qui
stimulerait les entreprises parce qu'on
voit bien que une grande partie des
émissions sont chez elles je pense que
ça serait bon et après il faut tenir la
longueur parce que encore faut-il
pouvoir donner ce plan mais après il
faut pouvoir communiquer régulièrement
et c'est ça qui est difficile dans
l'écologie parce qu'on sait que les
transformations sont très lentes donc si
on arrive à faire accepter il faut
arriver à entretenir un petit peu les
petites victoires qu'il y aura au fur et
à mesure parce que sinon ça fait dans 30
ans on va gagner quelques degrés mais
vous rendez compte d'ici 30 ans des gens
abandonneront évidemment les efforts je
suis d'accord avec vous je pense qu'il
faut donner enfin il faut donner du sens
à l'action publique c'est ça qui c'est
vraiment ce qui manque et je vais vous
dire on est allé il y a trois ans en
Suède comprendre la Suède elle a démarré
il y a plus de 20 ans plusieurs pays
d'Europe du Nord et ils ont eu un moment
de grosses difficultés et nous ont dit
l'essentiel c'est pour l'acceptation il
faut des politiques d'accompagnement et
notamment et notamment pour ceux qui ont
le moins de moyens parce qu'ils ont
l'impression de d'avoir une double peine
ils sont ils habitent dans les
territoires ruraux en périphérie des
villes c'est moins accessible ils ont
moins de moyens et on leur met des
injonctions vous le disiez genre on va
pas refaire l'histoire mais si on se
souvient l'élection de Nicolas Sarkozy
Grenelle de l'environnement et puis et
puis un an après ça commence à bien
faire vous voyez ce que je veux dire il
y a eu il y a eu une crise il y a une
grosse crise économique une crise
bancaire qui est arrivé juste après je
suis d'accord de minutes mais quand même
quoi là on a perdu certainement une une
occasion historique sur ce cette
question du rythme et de l'acceptation
je veux bien vous entendre là-dessus à
nos parce que il y a souvent un argument
qui est donné par ceux qui disent ça va
trop vite il y a de la casse sociale
liée à la transformation écologique on
prend l'exemple le plus facile c'est
passer de voiture thermique à voiture
électrique avec moi de main d'oeuvre
pour les produits etc etc enfin je vais
pas refaire toute la démonstration mais
mais qu'est-ce qu'on peut répondre à cet
argument là c'est vrai d'abord le
constat que l'État est soumis à des
injonctions contradictoires tout le
temps taper sur le politique
effectivement on prenons un exemple l'an
dernier l'État en même temps à un
discours très ambitieux de lutte contre
le changement climatique qui suppose de
moins consommer de pétrole par exemple
d'hydrocarbures et en même temps il a
sorti le porte-monnaie par millions
d'euros il a subventionné encouragé
soutenu la consommation d'hydrocarbures
est-ce que c'était sa faute vous avez vu
effectivement tous ces automobilistes
est-ce que c'était social non parce que
c'était pas les plus pauvres qui avaient
les plus gros réservoirs qui faisaient
les plus grandes distances etc etc on
est d'un point de vue écologique rien
n'allait pour autant et qui qui a
objectivement jeté la pierre à Bruno Le
Maire pour les mesures qu'il a prises
pas grand monde j'observe même que j'ai
pas entendu beaucoup de personnalités
politiques critiquer les ristourne sur
le sur le le livre de carburant les
décrets ont permis l'augmentation
successive de cette aide ou même en cas
du projet de loi finance quand on
regarde les votes que ça soit au Sénat
que ce soit l'Assemblée nationale final
sur tous les bancs il y a eu des votes
pour ce type de mesure de soutien la
consommation d'hydrocarbures donc ce qui
veut dire que c'est on est même pas dans
un débat majorité opposition on est dans
un débat où le politique est soumis à
des injonctions contradictoires entre il
faut lutter contre le changement
climatique et non ça ne va pas on veut
pouvoir consommer ce carbure il est
toujours dans une sorte de logique de
court terme alors qu'il faudrait faire
des actions à long terme alors qui
mettent à contribution je rappelle que
la première ministre elle évoque elle
appelle un effort collectif tiens on
écoute Elisabeth borne pour être
acceptable la planification écologique
doit être juste et équitablement
répartie
face à l'ampleur de l'enjeu chacun doit
prendre sa part et personne ne doit se
reposer sur les efforts des autres c'est
une question d'efficacité mais aussi une
question de justice et d'acceptation des
changements à venir
l'effort de réduction des émissions de
gaz à effet de serre sera donc porté par
tous à hauteur des émissions réalisées
des capacités et des moyens de chacun
au total la moitié de l'effort sera
accomplie par les entreprises notamment
les grandes entreprises un quart par
l'État et les collectivités et le
dernier quart par les ménages allez on
commence par les entreprises la moitié
de l'effort accomplie par les
entreprises notamment les plus grandes
Arnaud bossements est-ce que elles ont
pris la mesure de ce défi très
sincèrement je pense que oui quand on
regarde les secteurs dans lequel les
entreprises sont aujourd'hui
performantes investissent recrute ce
sont pourtant des secteurs dans lesquels
l'État parfois envoie des signaux
contradictoires je pense par exemple au
secteur de la production d'énergie
renouvelables je pense au secteur des
déchets de l'économie circulaire vous
avez une myriade d'entreprise qui se
crée dans ce secteur-là des emplois des
jeunes qui veulent travailler malgré un
cadre réglementaire extrêmement
contraint donc oui l'enthousiasme des
jeunes diplômés à vouloir travailler
dans ces secteurs là à investir ces
entreprises l'envie de ces entreprises
de faire oui mais c'est un peu mon job
je pense que ces entreprises au
quotidien le cadre réglementaire
n'incite pas forcément à trop compliqué
il y a trop d'empilement de texte il
faut tiens je vais vous poser la
question différemment est-ce que vous
reprenez la phrase Emmanuel Macron quand
il dit il faut peut-être calmer le jeu
au niveau des des réglementations
européennes et arrêter de rajouter des
règles contraignantes en matière de
transformation de sens parce
qu'évidemment que nous notamment pour
répondre aux nouveaux défis qui se
posaient à nous il va falloir des
nouvelles normes les entreprises
elles-mêmes produisent des normes des
chars des engagements etc etc donc le
problème c'est pas c'est plutôt la
qualité de la norme la lisibilité mais
regardez je vous prends un exemple si
vous voulez faire de l'éolien c'est une
énergie renouvelable l'état dit il faut
faire l'éolien ah mais non les paysages
etc etc vous voulez faire du solaire à
mais non c'est des panneaux en fait à
chaque fois il y a un truc pour faire en
sorte que l'objectif qui était toujours
très ambitieux qui est amené des gens à
créer des entreprises à vouloir s'y
investir on les fasse rétropédaler en
disant ah mais non parce qu'en fait vous
comprenez il y a des gens qui sont pour
qui sont contre que ça soit toutes les
énergies renouvelables solaires la
méthanisation ou l'éolien toutes sont
sous des feux contradictoires c'est
pareil pour les économies d'énergie il
faut en faire magnifique et regardez le
secteur du bâtiment aujourd'hui ou la
construction est quasiment à l'arrêt
avec des normes extrêmement complexes ça
me semble de qualification des ouvriers
pour faire ces pour faire et puis alors
les dispositifs d'économie d'énergie je
sais pas si vous avez déjà essayé de
comprendre ce que c'est qu'un certificat
d'économie d'énergie c'est c'est un
enfer donc là un moment donné on a
besoin de d'interlocuteurs Unis de
simplicité d'accompagner les gens pas
que par le financement parce qu'il y a
des financements mais les gens les
connaissent même pas il y a des
personnes qui vont faire des chantiers
de rénovation énergétique de leur
logement sans savoir forcément à quelles
aides ils ont le droit de la part de la
commune de la région de l'État là aussi
il y aurait besoin d'expliquer
d'accompagner pas que par l'argent ça
serait important alors moi il y a une
annonce qui m'avait marquée c'était au
mois de septembre début septembre deux
entreprises sont des entreprises
mutualistes Crédit Mutuel d'un côté MAIF
de l'autre créer une telle annonce 15%
de ses bénéfices consacrés à on va dire
la transformation environnementale et
sociétale et la MAIF 10% Élise à si les
198 autres de grandes entreprises
françaises font la même chose on finance
la transition est-ce que c'est vrai ça
nous c'est ce qu'on propose en tout cas
chez oxem c'est comme ça qu'on a étudié
les bilans des entreprises alors leur
bilan carbone et leur bilan financiers
effectivement on trouve que si les
entreprises au lieu de verser beaucoup
de dividendes à leurs actionnaires
notamment les grandes entreprises
investissaient une partie de ces
dividendes pour la transformation
écologique la transformation écologique
pourrait être financée et c'est
là-dessus que je rejoins Arnaud gossemin
dans le fait que il faut accompagner les
entreprises les grandes entreprises
comme les petites peut-être avec des
règles différentes pour leur donner une
contrainte une contrainte supplémentaire
c'est-à-dire notamment sur le versement
de dividendes ce serait ça pourrait être
effectivement une règle sur
l'orientation des dividendes qui
permettrait de financer la
transformation des entreprises
aujourd'hui par exemple dans le plan de
relance après le covid du gouvernement
on a eu beaucoup d'argent public qui a
été versé aux entreprises et le quoi
qu'il en coûte bien sûr et c'était
nécessaire pour l'économie française
mais sans aucune sans aucune contrainte
écologique sans aucune orientation en
fait c'est pas tellement une question de
contrainte de de choses qui nous
empêcheraient de d'aller quelque part
mais plutôt orienter et c'est là que la
puissance publique c'est là que l'État a
son rôle à jouer orienter les
entreprises vers le de la décarbonation
de la transformation écologique
effectivement aussi sur les questions de
biodiversité d'usage de l'eau des
matériaux etc je reprends cette
proposition
orientée les dividendes contraintes
finalement les entreprises à orienter
leur dividendes vers des investissements
de transformation mentale je pense que
c'est pas forcément les dividendes il
faut simplement que dans l'organisation
une fois qu'il y a des gains et profits
je pense qu'il en faut c'est la première
chose il faut répartir une partie sur
l'intéressement des salariés parce qu'il
y a rien de tel que d'être motivé et la
deuxième orientation évidemment
aujourd'hui me semble-t-il une des
priorités c'est accompagner et de donner
des indications des avantages pour
l'entreprise et pour nos sociétés à
s'orienter dans la transition
énergétique économique environnement
forcément en rémunérant moins les
actionnaires parce que c'est de ça donc
on parle quand on parle ça veut dire que
globalement il y aura une moindre
rémunération des actionnaires et qui va
apporter un autre avantage c'est de
donner de nouvelles perspectives de
développement et d'activités de
dynamique pour les entreprises
simplement en étant également au service
du développement de la qualité
environnementale c'est ça notre sujet
c'est la santé environnementale et ça ça
a un coût enfin demain c'est moins de
coût parce que par ses avantages vous
êtes sur la qualité de la santé
environnementale la prévention et
finalement sur
c'est une comment dirais-je c'est sur
des nouveaux atouts c'est ça aujourd'hui
et je pense que quelque part l'ambition
du Crédit Mutuel moi j'ai suivi d'assez
Nicolas Terrisse qu'il propose et le
patron c'est bien parce que vous avez
bien les salariés vous avez les clients
et vous avez un projet sociétal un
projet d'entreprise je pense qu'il faut
que CSM et dans ce cas-là je continue de
dire on gagnera parce qu'en plus ça veut
dire que derrière il y aura moins
d'impôts alors à ma connaissance j'ai
pas depuis septembre pas entendu
d'autres grandes entreprises dire on
embray on suit intervenir rapidement
une articulation entre le court terme et
le moyen long terme aujourd'hui les
décisions qui sont prises notamment dans
des grandes entreprises c'est vraiment
des bénéfices des dividendes à court
terme et puis demain peut-être que ADN
que pourra peu importe ce qu'il
admiendra de l'entreprise alors que
réorienter les investissements vers la
transformation écologique c'est une
vision de long terme et donc c'est aussi
une vision qui est plus positive pour
l'entreprise et pour les entreprises des
grandes entreprises qu'on cette vision
de long terme et qui se dit de toute
façon si on change plein de modèles on
sera on disparaître dans quelques années
alors il y a une dans ce débat Émilie
voilà autour de ce plan climat et de la
transformation transition écologique on
reparle de la taxation des plus riches
mais oui chasser la mauvaise idée par la
porte elle revient par la fenêtre depuis
le son premier quinquennat en fait
Emmanuel Macron fait de la taxation des
plus riches un sujet totalement tabou
l'une de ses premières mesures en tant
que Président vous vous en souvenez
sûrement c'était la suppression de
l'impôt sur la fortune ça lui avait valu
l'étiquette du président des riches
sobriqués qui a refait son apparition
d'ailleurs au moment de la réforme des
retraites alors c'est un peu avec
amusement qu'on peut voir la proposition
de gens Pisani Ferri dans son rapport
qui avait été commandé par Matignon Jean
Pisani Ferri ce n'est autre qu'un
conseiller un ancien conseiller
économiste économique d'Emmanuel Macron
en 2017 alors que propose Jean Pisany
ferry que j'ai appelé Edouard dans mes
titres je ne sais pas pourquoi qu'est-ce
qui propose pour financer la transition
écologique et l'homme propose plusieurs
options dont une taxation exceptionnelle
du patrimoine financier des plus aisés
en gros taxer les plus riches pour
financer tous ces investissements qu'il
considère à hauteur de 60 milliards
d'euros par an les 10% les plus riches
détiennent 3000 milliards d'euros un
prélèvement de 5% sur 30 ans
rapporterait 150 milliards d'euros
explique l'économie réponse immédiate du
ministre de l'économie on l'a entendu
tout à l'heure c'est niet il ne veut
absolument pas en entendre parler par
contre Bruno Le Maire se concentre sur
les autres options envisagées par France
stratégie dans ce rapport comme
notamment le redéploiement des dépenses
défavorables à l'environnement son
projet de loi sur l'industrie verte va
d'ailleurs dans ce sens alors sur ce
thème qu'est-ce qu'on a entendu de la
part d'autres membres du gouvernement
alors le même son de cloche du côté
d'Olivier Véran le porte-parole qui se
demandait ce matin sur France Inter si
la fiscalité était vraiment la bonne
solution en revanche la mesure a reçu
plutôt un écho favorable de la part du
ministre de la transition écologique
Christophe Béchu qu'on entendait tout à
l'heure dans quotidien il a signé
signalé que la proposition c'était sujet
tabou et pour lui même la question de la
mobilisation d'une finance climat
pourrait aider les pays du Sud se poser
aussi bien à l'échelle mondiale qu'à
l'échelle de notre pays évidemment les
idées de France stratégie on fait
beaucoup d'euros dans l'opposition du
côté des écologistes notamment puisque
l'ISS climatique ça faisait partie de
leur programme et on entend les
remerciements très appuyés de Cyrielle
châtelain député écologiste alors on les
entend sur Twitter elle dit merci à Jean
Pisani Ferri de participer à ce débat et
de rappeler que la contribution des plus
riches est une proposition crédible et
souhaitable cette question elle est dans
l'air depuis pas mal de temps alors oui
on en entend parler elle a été posée
après la crise covid pour essayer de
financer tous les efforts déployés pour
protéger les uns et les autres puis au
moment de la réforme des retraites
pourquoi pas et une centaine d'euros
députés et d'économistes ont signé il y
a quelques semaines une tribune pour la
création d'un impôt mondial sur la
fortune des ultra riches certains pays
se sont déjà lancés dans l'aventure
comme les États-Unis mais jusque là donc
le gouvernement ne veut pas en entendre
parler et ça serait étonnant qu'il lâche
du lest à ce sujet notamment pour la
transition écologique puisque comme on
le disait tout à l'heure les bénéfices
ne seront visibles que d'ici une
trentaine d'années dans le meilleur des
cas mais après comme on dit il y a que
les imbéciles changent pas la ligne on
verra bien alors je suis curieux de vous
entendre là-dessus parce que je pense
vous n'êtes pas forcément d'accord les
les uns les autres je commence avec vous
Elise nakarato parce que c'est l'une des
idées d'Oxfam depuis depuis longtemps la
taxation des plus riches pour financer
la transition tout à fait on a sorti un
dernier rapport à ce sujet en 2021 sur
spécifiquement l'impôt sur la fortune
climatique donc on n'est pas exactement
sur les mêmes modalités que ce que
propose monsieur design ferry mais ce
qui ce que nous on propose c'est
effectivement une taxation des
milliardaires pour financer la
transition pourquoi pas uniquement pour
capter de l'argent pour l'investir ça
c'est une bonne chose mais aussi pour
orienter ses investissements CTR que les
personnes qui ont énormément d'argent
par exemple les milliardaires ils vont
investir ils investissent dans
l'économie française donc nous ce qu'on
propose c'est une taxation différenciée
entre en gros des investissements bruns
et des investissements verts en fonction
de leurs investissements Israël en
fonction de récompensés ou puni quoi en
fonction de la de la de la verdure
est-ce que l'investissement est
décarboné ou plus carbonée est-ce qu'il
est favorable biodiversité ou pas il
serait accès différemment ce qui permet
d'une part d'engranger des bénéfices
pour financer la transition et d'autre
part de d'orienter parce que moi si
j'avais des milliards je préférerais
qu'il soit moins taxés donc j'aurais
tendance à aller les investir dans des
entreprises dans des projets qui sont
plus vertueux pour l'environnement ou
bien si je suis propriétaire de mon
entreprise d'encrelancher des plans de
transition écologique donc c'est ça
l'idée qu'on a derrière cette cette ISSF
climatique comporte depuis assez
longtemps avec d'autres organisations et
ce qu'on dit surtout c'est que la
transformation écologique qui est devant
nous ce un peu dont on a parlé de depuis
une demi-heure c'est elle est par nature
inégalitaire donc si on ne fait rien si
on laisse les choses aller telles
qu'elles sont ce sont les plus précaires
ce sont que ce soit les individus ou les
plus petits entreprises qui vont payer
le plus lourd tribu donc on a besoin de
d'orientation et y compris en matière de
finances pour contrer un peu cette
nature inégalitaire de la transformation
écologique les plus riches les
milliardaires peut-être d'ailleurs avec
cette idée ça va plus loin que ce que
Jean-Pierre ani ferry et évoquait dans
son rapport c'est beaucoup plus précis
que ce que vous nous dites que comment
vous réagissez à ça Jean-François ils
sont vous allez pas être surpris je vais
rester dans la même logique qui est
celle que je défends depuis un certain
temps
juste quand même se dire deux trois
choses en France on est quasiment les
champions d'Europe et on est très bien
place au niveau de la fiscalité on a en
même temps quasiment les comptes publics
les moins bons d'Europe donc si on pense
qu'avec ces éléments-là boom on peut y
aller et forcément il faut accélérer
riches je pense que c'est un peu
réducteur et je pense qu'il faut
orienter notre capacité d'investissement
privé réorienter l'épargne vers les
entreprises au bénéfice de de de cet
effort climatique et je le dis d'autant
plus volontiers que par exemple vous
prenez le secteur de l'assurance vie il
y a quand même quelques milliers de
milliards d'euros je me heurte
aujourd'hui dans le secteur de
l'assurance à la possibilité de
transférer les comptes de l'Assurance
Vie au bout d'un certain temps pour
redynamiser l'économie parce que on a
quand même sur du long terme et là on
pourrait avoir de l'épargne à long terme
dont une partie est détenue par les uns
et les autres par des des c'est pas que
des riches c'est aussi pourquoi pas
certaines on est sur le long terme on
accompagne à ce moment-là grâce à des
entreprises qui elles également
entreprennent le verdissement de leur
pratique au bénéfice finalement d'une
meilleure qualité de vie C'est ça la
vraie réussite parce que Bruno Le Maire
disait moi j'avais regardé les deux
derniers des cils qui payent l'impôt sur
le revenu le plus ils en payent presque
86%. alors il disait 75%
mais mais passons c'est pas c'est pas
neutre donc est-ce qu'on pense qu'il n'y
a que ça et puis il faut quand même
faire attention un peu on a dans un
monde ouvert ce que la France mettra
comme condition plus draconiennes pour
celles et ceux qui ont une certaine
richesse et je vais vous dire ça va
bouger les capitaux voilà il faut voilà
il faut aussi faire attention à tout ça
donc il faut rechercher des équilibres
mais il faut donner un coup
d'accélérateur pour permettre un
investissement par le plus grand nombre
on a bien compris votre avis là-dessus
sur la proposition de de DSF VR on va
dire ça comme ça alors ce qui est
amusant c'est que j'ai l'impression que
peu ont lu le rapport de Monsieur Pisani
Ferri et d'ailleurs ils sont expliqués
dans une conférence de presse auprès des
journalistes hier avec une
retranscription que vous pouvez les lire
dans le journal notamment libération il
ne parle pas du tout d'issf et il s'en
est d'ailleurs défendu ni et c'est
exceptionnel
pas d'ISF et il ne veut pas non plus une
quelcon prélèvement sur les capitaux
financiers or tout le monde qu'est-ce
qui reste dans ce cas là je ne sais pas
page 121 du rapport y écrit augmentation
exceptionnelle temporaire des
prélèvements obligatoires c'est quoi ça
peut être une impôt une taille je ne
sais pas ce que c'est c'est très très
vaste quand même de manière
exceptionnelle exceptionnelle temporaire
alors c'est temporaire c'est quoi parce
que en matière de fiscalité c'est
contemporaine
ne l'a jamais été donc je crains une
certaine résistance et après il dit 10%
des plus aisés sur leur patrimoine mais
quel patrimoine à quel moment c'est le
patrimoine à venir c'est le patrimoine
instant T regard de critères écologiques
lesquels il y a rien dans le rapport
là-dessus absolument c'est ce qu'il y a
trois pages non pour moi c'est une
fausse proposition derrière le rapport
c'est amusant il a fait l'objet d'un
trade sur Twitter de France stratégie à
aucun moment à l'intérieur il reprenne
cette idée là et il s'en est dans une
fois défendu ce qui est intéressant
c'est de rappeler juste la fonction de
la fiscalité pour injurie ces deux
choses 1 c'est financier une politique
publique donc vous demandez à des gens
de verser de l'argent pourquoi pas
effectivement en fonction de leur
empreinte environnementale déjà il va
falloir la définir l'empreinte
environnementale deux vous financer quoi
il y a un principe d'université de
l'impôt ce qui veut dire que les sommes
qui viennent de l'impôt par exemple je
sais pas l'ISSF ouifi aujourd'hui etc
vont dans le budget de l'État et après
ça peut aller dans le ministère de la
Défense ça peut aller dans le solde le
service de la dette qui est le deuxième
poste budgétaire de comment garantir que
c'est argent soit fléchés vers
l'écologie première chose deuxième chose
le taux rien là-dessus c'est quand même
très important parce que si vous faites
un taux bas c'est un droit à détruire si
par exemple vous faites une taxe carbone
basse ben il y a des gens qui vont se
dire ah bah c'est très bien je vais
continuer comme avant j'aurai ce droit à
des permis de polluer quoi dire que la
taxe peut produire l'effet exactement à
ce qu'on l'a eu par exemple avec la taxe
sur les déchets ou des élus locaux se
disait c'est plus intéressant d'aller en
décharge que d'aller dans le recyclage
et si vous permettez juste encore un
tout petit point là-dessus la deuxième
chose c'est de modifier les
comportements lors du Grenelle on
s'était mis d'accord sur le fait qu'il
fallait aussi modifier les comportements
par une modification de la fiscalité à
l'époque c'était la taxe carbone un
impôt exceptionnel vous allez pas
modifier les comportements de l'ensemble
d'une population d'un tissu économique
c'est une mesure gadget à un instant T
ça fait ça permet de contrat
contrebalancer le reste du rapport qui
lui est très macroniste il est pour la
croissance verte il est pour il est
contre la décroissance etc il y a tout
le vocabulaire Macron jusqu'à la page
121 ou là on dit tiens il y a un truc
mais quand même on a réussi à les faire
par exemple sur les super profits des
énergéticiens ça
propose une taxe de 5% quand même un
chiffre quand même
en tout cas dans les explications bon
allez je reprends la main parce qu'il
nous reste moins de 10 minutes et je
voudrais Quentin calmer nous nous
rejoignent bonsoir Quentin pour évoquer
la question de de d'une consultation et
notamment de ce que le ministre de la
transition écologique Christophe a
annoncé réflexion sur l'adaptation de la
France au réchauffement climatique oui
c'est vrai que fin avril les satellites
européens du réseau Copernicus ont
démontré que l'Europe et le continent
qui se réchauffe le plus vite dans le
monde les températures augmentent même
d'ailleurs deux fois plus vite sur le
continent européen que la moyenne
mondiale et on a vu cette double page
dans le Journal du Dimanche le
gouvernement se tournerait vers une
trajectoire de plus 3% dans le monde
d'ici 2100 et même plus 4 degrés pardon
pour à la France on parle bien de degrés
Christophe bechut veut donc une grande
consultation citoyenne sur le sujet il
l'a lancé ce matin l'idée est de se
préparer au cru au feu aux inondations
écoutez donc le ministre de la
transition écologique au micro de
Jonathan du priez en aucun cas ça n'est
du défaitisme ou du renoncement
l'engagement l'ambition c'est de baisser
nos émissions et de tenir nos
engagements climatiques et donc de
doubler notre rythme de baisse des
émissions ça c'est au cœur de l'action
de la première ministre et c'était au
cœur hier de cet exercice inédit d'un
Conseil national de la transition
écologique mais dans le même temps on
peut pas regarder des expertises et des
rapports qui nous disent on va vers 4
degrés et ne pas préparer notre pays à
ce que serait une France à 4 degrés une
France à 4 degrés le ministre de donner
des exemples concrets diminution de
l'enneigement multiplication des
sécheresses par 5 dit-il doublement de
la montée des eaux et de l'érosion des
traits de côtes c'est tout cela une
France a plus 4 degrés Celsius d'ici
2100 et donc cette consultation j'en
parlais avant une stratégie nationale
présentée plus tard dans l'année voilà
l'idée c'est de permettre aux Français
de s'approprier la trajectoire de la
hausse des températures et de donner
leur point de vue pour éviter les angles
morts aussi de la politique du
gouvernement ensuite le gouvernement
présentera un plan national un plan
national dont on connaît déjà
l'esquisse écouter à nouveau Christophe
Béchu on va lancer cette stratégie
nationale autour de trois grands volets
modifier les référentiels techniques
dans une France où on a des pics de
température à 50 degrés ce que nos
infrastructures de transport nos réseaux
de télécommunications sont assez
résilients deuxième volet toute la
partie collectivité territoriale et vie
au quotidien il eau de fraîcheur des
minéralisations des imperméabilisations
des sols plantation d'arbres tout ce qui
nous permettra de faire face à une
partie de ses volets là et enfin un
volet plus économique sur la continuité
et des services publics et des activités
les Français qui peuvent donner leur
avis par email jusqu'à mi septembre le
plan national d'adaptation sera lui
présenter à la fin de l'année Thomas
merci beaucoup Quentin Élise nacarato
votre avis sur sur cette consultation
parce que c'est intéressant parce que
c'est pas parce qu'on se dit il faut
préparer une éventuelle trajectoire à
plus 4 degrés en 2100 qu'on l'accepte et
qu'on fait rien pour pour l'éviter vous
voyez ce que je veux dire j'aimerais que
ce soit effectivement ça qui se passe
aujourd'hui les preuves concrète
d'action ne vont pas dans le sens
puisque on a d'un côté un ministre qui
dit il faut se préparer à 4 degrés ce
qui est une réalité c'est ce que prévoit
les trajectoires du GIEC entre autres
donc il y a pas de surprise sur ce
chiffre de 4 degrés effectivement
aujourd'hui la France n'est pas prête et
c'est une bonne chose que de réfléchir à
quels sont nos infrastructures mais
quand de l'autre côté on a un état qui a
été condamné deux fois pour une action
climatique on a un état qui n'a pas pris
les mesures depuis des années sur la
réduction de ces émissions de gaz à
effet de serre en fait c'est deux sons
de cloche qui sont incohérents et
effectivement la pour faire face à la
crise climatique il faut absolument
avoir ces deux leviers activés en même
temps l'adaptation donc comment est-ce
qu'on vit dans un monde à plus trois
plus quatre degrés et l'atténuation donc
réduire nos émissions de gaz à effet de
serre sinon c'est un peu comme si vous
essayez d'arrêter de fumer vous mettez
un patch mais vous continuez à acheter
des clopes ça n'a vraiment aucun sens
donc on a on a vraiment besoin des deux
aujourd'hui on annule l'un ni l'autre
Jean-François ce qui est un peu
perturbant avec cette consultation on a
bien compris c'est une projection sur le
long terme voilà essayer d'esquisser des
solutions si on ne réussit pas à éviter
cette trajectoire à plus quatre degrés
mais c'est que dans le même temps il y a
des lois qui arrivent dans les
prochaines semaines donc c'est un peu
perturbant
sur toute la ligne c'est
incompréhensible on a une élection
présidentielle on va se dire pas de
chance puisque déclaration de guerre
Ukraine Russie deux mois avant donc il
s'est rien passé il y a pas eu de débat
mais c'est plutôt la Russie qui a envahi
le cri on va dire ça comme ça mais c'est
pas grave voilà il y a pas de souci mais
je l'anticipe les critiques qui
pourraient vous êtes fait avec cette
formulation voilà une mauvaise
expression pour moi mais en fait
quand on est un gouvernement avec un
prêt dans la République on définit un
projet faute de l'avoir défini on pose
les fondamentaux et puis à ce moment-là
on consulte et ensuite on tire des
premières conclusions pour lancer les
projets pour rentrer moi je adaptation
atténuation il y a aucun souci
d'ailleurs ça traverse les majorités ça
fait une dizaine d'années de qu'on parle
ou même 20 ans comme l'efficacité tout
ça c'est bon mais par contre cette
illisible en terme de méthode parce que
aujourd'hui on nous a hier on nous a dit
beaucoup plus on nous a dit on va voir
la stragénie nationale bas carbone la
stratégie nationale biodiversité pas
tout est prêt jusque en gros la fin de
l'année avec 6 textes différents mais
j'ai envie de dire de qui se moque-t-on
oui mais là c'est deux consultations
différentes on l'a bien compris c'est
c'est il y a des textes il y a une
consultation sur l'adaptation à
2100 quoi
enfin pour moi il y a des démarches qui
sont
perturbantes qui peuvent être
contradictoires parce que l'objectif si
on consulte les Français c'est quand
même de faire en sorte qu'ils adhèrent
et donc si à l'inverse la machine est à
se gripper il faudra pas s'étonner votre
avis un point de précision d'abord un la
stratégie plus 4 degrés d'ici à 2100 ce
n'est pas nouveau ça date de 2006 c'est
même inscrit dans une stratégie
nationale de d'adaptation changement
climatique du gouvernement et c'est dit
par le GIEC deux ce n'est pas le
scénario le plus pessimiste
contrairement à ce qui a été dit mais
c'est dans le plus pessimiste c'est plus
7 degrés et encore sur l'année ce qui
veut dire qu'on était ça va être pire et
trois surtout faut pas oublier que le
gouvernement a la suite de cette
information en 2006 publié des plans
nationaux d'adaptation changement
climatique dont personne
n'en a parlé le dernier s'est achevé en
2022 normalement au gouvernement aurait
dû faire le bilan du Knack là
aujourd'hui et derrière proposer un
nouveau plan national d'adaptation
changement climatique pour gagner du
temps on nous annonce en 2024 alors que
normalement c'est urgent faut le faire
tout de suite mais on va attendre 2024
et on a un sondage en ligne qui n'est
pas une consultation publique avec trois
questions je sais pas si vous êtes allés
les lire la première question c'est
êtes-vous d'accord pour que la France
respecte la trajectoire de réchauffement
climatique issue de l'accord de Paris
mais c'est terrible parce que j'espère
bien qu'on la respecte en s'est engagé à
le faire enfin c'est des questions pour
enfants de 2 ans dont la réponse est
totalement évidente la réponse est déjà
dans notre droit on se dit là c'est un
exercice donc c'est une communication
c'est pas une vraie consultation mais
par contre il y a un retour d'expérience
quand même qui est assez clair et
concret c'est pendant la pénurie enfin
quand on a craint une pénurie d'énergie
et quand les prix ont fortement augmenté
et ben on a vu que la population
réagissait donc c'est pas forcément sous
la contrainte enfin ce que je veux dire
c'est que les gens sont aussi
responsables même si parfois on a on
veut un peu les deux mais je pense qu'il
faut tenir compte de ça et on a
l'impression qu'on n'en tient pas compte
alors qu'il y a eu véritablement après
le plan de sobriété des effets
probablement guidés par l'inflation au
niveau des entreprises c'est pareil et
ça je pense qu'il faudrait s'appuyer
davantage dessus alors qu'on pense que
bah les gens font un peu n'importe quoi
ils vont ils vont pas avoir envie de
réduire leur consommation un mot
là-dessus de conclusion les gens sont
responsables mais la question c'est dans
quelle mesure est-ce qu'ils ont la
capacité aujourd'hui moi en tant que
citoyenne en fait mais mais mes
capacités d'actions elles sont assez
limitées et c'est pour ça qu'on a besoin
d'un gouvernement d'un État qui donne
des orientations qui changent des
politiques ça suffit plus quoi c'est
essentiel mais effectivement ça ne
suffit plus on entend parler de
stratégie de de planification écologique
depuis des années où était-elle merci
beaucoup merci à tous d'avoir participé
à ce à ce débat je vous dis à bientôt
sur Public Sénat